[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: Making your
app big puts it at risk
to suffer from all
these downsides.
Bigger apps lose acquisitions,
and bigger apps also
get uninstalled
to free up space.
I'm sure you already know that.
And you've probably
just considered it
a trade-off that
you add new features
and support more
device configurations
but lose installs and
drive more uninstalls.
We don't want you to have to
worry about these trade-offs.
SPEAKER 2: That App Bundle
is the official Android app
publishing format.
Apps that have already
adopted the bundle
are seeing an average
size saving of 35%.
That's compared to a universal
APK, and that's quite a lot.
All these developers
around the world
have switched and are seeing
fantastic size savings.
Duolingo, for example,
saw a 56% size saving
compared to a universal APK.
And it's really hard
to get such big savings
from incremental optimizations.
SPEAKER 1: We've added a new
Android platform optimisation
to the App Bundle called
uncompressed native libraries.
Here's how it works.
On Android L and
below, native libraries
have to be uncompressed
from the APK
before the platform
can use them,
meaning the user ends up with
two copies of the library.
After Android M, the
platform can read the library
directly from the APK if it's
left uncompressed, thus saving
a copy on the device.
To do it yourself,
you would need
to upload two
versions of your app
and create multi APK
for pre- and post-M.
If you're using the App
Bundle, you just give us
your libraries, and we create
the required flavor for pre-
and post-M and serve the
right APK to the right user.
Dynamic features can
be installed on demand
when user requests them.
Or you can choose to defer
installing them to a later time
when the app goes
to the background.
For pre-L devices which don't
support on-demand features,
we can fuse the modules
into the main app
so they're delivered
at install time.
All of these use
cases are supported
in production
to-date, with millions
of users benefiting already.
Now that we've created
our on-demand modules,
let's write the code
to download them.
In order to interact
with the Play Store
to request these
on-demand modules,
we have to use the split
install API which is
part of the Play core library.
This is a Java client
library that communicates
with the Play Store via IPC.
SPEAKER 2: Android Studio and
Gradle are not the only ways
that you can build
bundles today.
Because the format and
bundle tool are open source,
others are already
adopting them.
For example, we're excited to
share that games using Unity
can now build Android
app bundles too.
Unity added support in
the 2018.3 beta release,
and you can join the
beta program now.
[MUSIC PLAYING]